welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar connected data
linking preclinical data to commercial
outcomes for patients today it is
presented by Wu Engagement Manager and
Ernst & Young my name is Judy O'Rourke
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots lab roots is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before I begin I would like
to remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming whoo I will now
turn the presentation over to him hello
everybody thank you for joining me today
as I tell you about how data today is
more connected than ever especially
looking at preclinical data all the way
through to commercial and patient
outcomes
so the content I would like to go over
today is really looking at the evolving
value chain I think this probably
changed something that you are probably
very familiar with in order to talk
about how data is changing under the
value chain that we look at today I
would like to show you some models a
little bit about our past and also what
are the trends of the future
secondly I would love to talk about the
lab of the future and what does that
actually mean in terms of the
implications to data and I'm sure this
is a buzzword that you've heard but in
terms of this conversation I want to
frame
how does the lab the future and impact
the number of data and data points not I
think we can be collecting especially in
the clinical space and how does that
inform commercial and vice-versa and in
section 3 really looking at how the
analytics landscape has really boomed
and shifted with some case studies to
follow in section 4 especially about
Novartis and what you guys have done in
order to really engage and partner in
this space to provide more insights and
analytics to the work that you guys are
doing and then finally what section 5
looking at what are the impacts of
real-world evidence
how has real-world evidence changed
items that we look at today in terms of
informing the type of clinical studies
we do and how we commercialize or in
agents to set us off as section 1 just a
norm everybody I really do want to talk
about the value chain of Pharma in a
very high-level way in addition to what
are some high-level buckets that are
changing especially as we look at pharma
2020 and beyond so looking at here just
taking a focus on let's just say
oncology for example you can see that in
traditional pharmaceutical landscapes
and value chains we really look at it in
I would say two pieces where you start
with something like a target lead and
preclinical and of course that is
followed by phases 1 2 3
filing commercial launch potentially a
phase board exit but that's something
that I think many of us within different
colors or verticals in our business
however as you see and as you know in
this more evolved version of Pharma
there are a lot more players
despite the value chain staying very
consistent however how the interactions
happen between each step within
pharmaceuticals
there's a lot more connectivity that's
required and a lot of data that's
generated to supply that connectivity so
what I mean why not is when looking at
molecular discovery and you still have
the target lead and preclinical space of
course before phase 1 2 3 filing launch
finally phase 4 but there is a lot more
partnerships today in terms of sharing
day
in understanding what our that large
academic sense is doing and for this
example let's just take on ecology and
what about the startup space and the
biotech space that is in that really
stands out and is different from
traditional pharma as we know in the
last decade or at least in you know from
2010 on the amount of biotech stats on
up the last ten years has really boomed
competitively - before we're you know
prides of 2010 we were looking at large
pharmaceuticals dominating I would say
most of the revenue and spend however
with our Tech's now although they spend
on R&D for example may not be obviously
as high as a traditional large
pharmaceutical however the amount in the
number of different auto-text exists
today at least let's just say in the US
as really I think 10 folded when looking
at two thousand two two thousand and
then of course how are we leveraging see
our other sources as we think about
phase one two three when we think of
that filing how are we looking at using
CRO either in preclinical and in
clinical in order to partner in parallel
to complete clinical trials haven't you
share that data how do we make sure we
maintain that data to make sure that is
it fused finally etc how do we relate
that back to each other but the
necessity for us to really understand
what has been done outside of our you
know our sphere our internal systems is
that the data complication that we did
not see as much in this traditional
pharmaceutical value chain but they
thank me is one of the drivers as you
see on the left is really a integrated
laboratory technology across many
disease areas I think this is something
that we are going towards understanding
well if we're going to look at different
disease areas if we were going from look
at preclinical trials or get lead
excetera in a holistic way to move us to
use things like predictive analytics and
big data we need a launching off point
in order to understand all the data in
some sort of orderly fashion
so there's integrated technologies how
do we catch the things all
my time how to report online time has
been a boon implied that I think you
know in the new Honda involved Italian
chain of course um this notion of nasta
failing if we can use data to increase
what we know then we can decide on what
is going to be successful versus not
earlier is something that we can always
recoup on finding cost which is the
issue I think for many years now then
obviously lastly licensing to implement
therapies how does what we do in the
preclinical space really impact how we
think about license and how we impact on
how we go to market in terms of
commercial what kind of therapies that
we want to put in and today the items
that we know for therapy implementation
on the race I which is looking at the
clinical phase one two three and this
profile in comes a lot how do we
streamline different commercial in
clinical data together so that we are
reporting on or if we do follow-up
clinical work that there is a healthy
feedback loop to see what happens in
commercial back to Kanpur and back right
now to be as many know due to regulatory
agencies that are blinding unblinding if
their data that can or cannot be shared
but if the data can be shared how is it
housed or how is it structured in a
waste no not the flow of data is
integral and is easy and one time vistas
siloed and kind of in chunk of areas I
would like to say which is more common
today or a common challenge met today
and then lastly
post commercial launch post let's say 18
months out if you're collecting the
world data what are the inflection
points where you can plug this reward
data in and what guy okay if we have
especially outcomes with real world data
where can we actually pivot and make
changes in a structure low like model
when it comes through the data um I
think one key thing with for moving on
is really to understand where in this
process are we looking naturally elevate
outcomes in thinking across or just the
very area so during preclinical phase
one phase
I think across the disciplinary area
knowing that the data that in generate
will also kind of end task I think where
it's cleaning that's something that's
very different meeting about traditional
formal which is we collect for our for
our I guess our vertical and then once
that time limit is achieved in the data
amount is achieved we can pass that on
the side if that makes the next phase so
this waterfall phase gate approach now
has it a lot more integrating active
cool because the data between all of
them is starting to tell the story
instead of passing it along you can
baton or a relay this will begin to
section two which is a little bit about
lab 53 and obviously this session is not
about the lab feature but I do want pull
up implications because a lot of future
does talk about very early clinical work
so how does the very beginnings of data
generation everything downstream so
going into the next slide really I think
a lot of the feature has four major
components as you may know the design
and configurations advancement in
process design advanced technologies and
enabled labs and of course employee
empowerment I think today for this
conversation and I think two things I
really want to focus on is really the
advanced technology enabled labs and
also the advanced process line because
it is those two areas where it kind of
cools the amount of data created
where this data lives how is the data
created was the hygiene structure
architecture because those are things
that we didn't look at as often in this
in this lab the future pre lab to be
just based because we never thought
about this data really being updated two
different feedback cycles or provided
others outside of and of our site so I
think when we think about does not even
lab with each other and lab design
configuration making sure that different
teammates areas of work are together
integrated the top left and the bottom
right I think are areas that are very
important for this question I think
looking at what assets you have per week
on enables
analytics
and you know predictive analytics even
if you have a feedback cycle and say
okay well if we do this today and we are
building the architecture today in this
way how we storing data sharing data
integrating data so that three years out
five years out when the data comes back
with no more evidence or when it passes
work there's been three phase 2 clinical
trial how is that coming back to us
inform our future build a prequel for
future lines of molecules device I think
really thinking about laboratory the
future those components really dwells on
the fact I once we go beyond what do we
do in our medical and what data is
necessary we also think about how is
data coming back to us what data points
are coming back to us and how does that
inform different decisions that we would
or would not make based on additional
capabilities I think I've said many
buzzword buzzwords up until now I think
one of the largest things that we think
about is we don't think about is how is
the data structured and what are the
inputs because in order to really
harness the power of any sort of
analytics there has to be some sort of
base or something for everybody to
integrate their data and having a
research background I know that between
disease areas between different
compounds between different offices or
locations or countries the way we
interact with a very manual or
systematic or the process of generating
insights could be very different and I
think as we look into this new farm
enabled conducted data ecosystem we
really need to think about how are we
all doing
maybe not the easiest thing but the most
standard thing so that all our data can
be harnessed in one place and to looked
at in one kind of cohesive real time men
of this is you know manual crunching of
data integrating and you know one time a
year because the data that we need to
make our business decisions
let it be preclinical or commercial is
needs to be more timely than not as it
demands from market pressure is much
greater than what's a year or even once
every quarter I think for three things
to pull from
is really as I mentioned advanced
technology technology that's omnipresent
in navigation is informed by an app or a
management system or a platform rather
than a human or a person so really
making sure that our things are
safeguarded and shielded versus a
real-time data aggregation and reporting
which is something I think I've said a
few times now which is really
understanding the shifting focus of how
data is collected so that it can be used
and honest um throughout the production
of a clinical trial and feedback after
we know the longevity of let's say that
trial and then lastly data collaboration
across the value chain where areas where
you would like more data up or down
stream depending on where you sit in
addition to what type of data would that
be how would that employment decisions
let it be a go/no-go or let it be
enhanced patient outreach or a certain
type of patient outreach or a type of
commercial model to come back you know
market forces and competitors in that
space this really moves us on to section
3 which is looking at the analytics and
partnerships so we talked a lot about
where data can sit what kind of data can
be generated how is the pharmaceutical
value chain very different than it was
let's say 20 years ago but I do want to
just share with you in a small kind of
POC setting our proof of concept
fighting which is just looking at the
number of birds that sit with some of
these verticals obviously this is
definitely not dispositive you can see
the number of analytical players or
health tech companies or Eyal health
companies that may not be a direct
competitor to let's say Novartis they're
not producing any drug but does not
updated and producing to support certain
pipelines of drugs has really expanded
in the last let's say five years so I'm
not gonna go into each one of these but
as you can see I put color coding to
look at what types of data they're
looking at and it gives you I would say
a flavor of what kind of data you know
could be coming to different various
verticals within the value chain in
addition to what
of areas dude a really Honus data let it
be a population health monitoring after
treatment or a diagnosis and patient
profiling is it a referral pattern item
or maybe is it early detection and
prevention I think what is a great that
I wanted to pull and specifically for
this audience is to really understand
there are a lot of different
partnerships that have already taken
place and looking at this landscape you
can see various names that you might
know in the large pharmaceutical top ten
big funders you know today but what I
did want to highlight is some of the
winds that Novartis has taken in terms
of understanding where do they want to
play with big data so you may know that
code of healthcare you motif IBM Watson
shift analytics are all things that
Nevada does have quick capital
allocation to partnerships to help us
get generating you know greater
real-world inside tailored
evidence-based cancer treatment
interventions to support more strategic
R&D spend in addition to things like the
shift analytics and Novartis partnership
really looking at how data is customized
between the interaction of oncologists
and payer providers and then lastly of
course on this bucket not we haven't
seen anything with Novartis yet which is
individualized Cancer Care solution look
at how do we manage on point of care
when it comes to selling therapies for
example so this gives you kind of a
flavor landscapes of people already
partnering with different technology or
health tech companies provide more data
insights to see how data really is
connected so it really goes beyond just
kind of the worlds and borders of your
company as these strategic partnerships
really will bring on the new wave of
competition how you use that data to
enter the market and stay competitive in
Department I think moving on really
quickly I think this is just another
view I think it's a lot less busy in
terms of a landscape this is just a very
clean slide that looks at
what are the advanced analytics and AI
generating evidence-based insights and
there are three dialect listed which is
Novartis shift analytics which is really
looking at intuitively the analytics for
driving decision-making for commercial
chains and I know this is very high
level as we don't want to get too
detailed but something that you ask
questions without into common thought
and of course the Novartis coda
healthcare a kind of partnership which
is leveraging kotas analytics platform
optimizing outcomes
probably just the recitation of breast
cancer patient line and then of course
the IBM Watson and the lordís what you
may have heard about in the objective is
really to equip oncologists with
evidence-based answers and expected
outcomes about the end the breast cancer
treatment process that they can make
them those employment decisions quick
data about other patients other things
by Novartis and IBM Watson have it as I
did it would you look at data this moves
on to section 4 which is the tune of
artist case studies that I put together
I would like to go through one and of
course there's the second one for you to
look at and the downloaded materials
like just a highlight one I think one
not thank you want to talk a little bit
more isn't Novartis as you may have
heard this believe slash line in March
of 2017 with a most idea a multi-year
agreement focused on just the u.s.
landscape what they're using is they
want to use the world war evidence
generated from cancer treatments in the
breast cancer space to really help with
things that they are still doing
problems with so I'm just planning on
work that is being done just by
personalization of one indication of the
product I think is exactly I'm trying to
highlight today how data is active than
ever that what it was 10 years ago
really the purpose is to optimize
component cost outcomes for the breast
cancer identifying patients who would
benefit from it those
line of that they target profiles
looking at what other sponsors didn't
need to know about the patient to really
optimize book for us the data that were
hoping distinctive gain from the
clinical trial in addition to what other
item but we need a yes based on world
other than to know that these patients
with these type of patients with Steve
or they receive XYZ better may respond
better they have more clinical success
there's more reproducibility would be
higher sloshed not you know I guess the
breath in reach of our clinical trial
that we may have to show may not be as
great is wearing some soju named
real-world evidence in order to help
this process a lot and I think one thing
I do want to mention I know it's quite
bulky down there but with the end do you
want to really talk about is CODIS
technology so you might think about okay
so yeah that sounds really great but I
think how we are actually doing that
from the data perspective is who this
technology is actually running and in
the system it can stratify patients so
based on patient outcomes in you
stratify patients based on attributes of
the prognosis in significance from you
know the original onset to post when
they start feeling certain types of
responses to the treatment and all of
that is aggregated and when we look at
things that to patients that they are
experiencing not results let's say a
positive outcome what it can do is it
can look at you know whatever patient's
they are where are they located how they
would the organization of pairs that's
around them what are one of the key one
of the discrete properties between these
two patients three four eight twelve and
data aggregate and what are the I guess
the inside keeping wing from those to
show that you know it doesn't matter if
they are in Kentucky this is you know
Portland Oregon or you know my name is
Florida add another geography son
geography but based on certain key
metrics that were seen with bone with
evidence or evidence from health
outcomes we can
say that you know patience that that
this prototype prototype or you know
model may respond better based on the
data that we sing with current patient
this helps as you may know to inform the
type of clinical trials that we would
need to do or how would you we use
real-world evidence which I'll get into
the last two really bother with if
regulatory agencies like the FDA in the
United States to say if we have this
real-world evidence then we would only
we would not need to reproduce certain
key pieces of clinical trials but use
that as a supplement and continue on
cause maybe with a different on the next
slide I'll flash really quickly but the
second case study I put together is the
Novartis and shift analytics which is
closed about mid last year which is
really is looking at third-party and
proprietary commercial data once a
project is in the commercial space but
over time purposes I think I will leave
this to you and if there's questions
about this one that you want to ask of
course feel free to go into chat box and
engage that but to move on to really
looking at real world data in the fifth
part of our conversation today which is
really looking at rule of evidence and
guidance on the feet so how does the
evidence that we generate with outcome
really guide us and how we do what we
are doing today across all verticals
before getting shoes equally and not I
do you want to just share some the high
level not everybody may know where our
inputs for things like real world data
today and of course this list is not
exhaustive as this throws you know every
every couple of months I think there are
different inputs that we can have in the
world world space but I tried to bucket
it in kind of four areas to help us
understand for this conversation
purposes like to record data indirect
data and patient data and provider data
but granted a visual that put together
isn't exactly quadrant it like that I
think helped us about the types of input
data that would fit under the real world
I guess buckets I'm really thinking
about
direct data being consumer level data
wearable data pharmacy pharmacy data I
think are all things that really touches
upon the consumer itself who is
receiving the treatment and the data
base of course then you look at patient
so patient data is of course our
indicted diagnosis data electronic
medical data survey data that they
either take during clinical trial after
clinical trial and during their
treatment or after new treatment where
you know as they're finishing up the
treatment of course provider data I
think that is the most that's the
easiest to understand so it's really
understanding on the hospital data any
additional pharmaceutical data pharmacy
data that we have claims data that's
filed between parent provider I think
are important data pieces that is now
informing us on how we do things within
our value chain in the pharmaceutical
landscape now lastly indirect data if we
have things about social media social
listening data in different platforms
the laboratory biomarkers data mortality
rates data I think all pieces together
into what we look at what patient
centricity and understanding real-world
evidence in this piece so I do want to
go in and look at how really the amount
of full-time resources to really look at
rolled evidence or just the you know the
thought of collecting real-world
evidence has really increased across
really if you think about globally I
think the rate of increased based on
economic pressures economic factors
weight hospital networks payer provider
is governed within each country may be a
little bit different but breaking up
into us your emerging markets and just
global as a whole you can see a trend
within 2013 2015 and 2017
now obviously the amount of FTEs that
spent or their time to spent looking
generating accepting using rule the
evidence has grown I think something
that's a very noteworthy is that
I think even though us may be a late
adopter to outcomes based treatments or
the leveraging and the use of real world
evidence or Arthur bees has really I
think we were the slowest to adopt but
our growth has been the highest in the
last couple of years as you see in this
data is from 2013 to 2017 versus I think
Europe has had a higher consumption rate
but they've had an inflection point be
250 years and then of course emerging
markets has grown quite a bit as well
in addition globally as a whole across
over you can see the trend is you know
growing from 1520 to 99 so as you know
the amount of allocation thinking in
connected use of data is definitely
growing so how do we use things
generated post commercial insights
throughout all of our verticals is
something that everybody in the industry
is spending more much time thinking
about as it's not only a time savings
but it's also a cost saving and labor
savings a understanding that it will be
more efficient in the way we do progress
and then lastly on I think just for the
simplicity bring it back to I would say
this Pharma evolved or this next bend
Pharma landscape but what I just put
here is just really easy tabs of where
real world evidence is usually generated
of course this is not exhaustive and
very high-level but what are some common
inflection points that we are seeing
across the industry where people are
leveraging real-world evidence let it be
you know in the verticals that we know
preclinical through phase three how we
generating real-world evidence with
large cancer centers versus sharing that
evidence so did we are kind of it's a
two-way communication street we're both
getting smarter and being more involved
in the way we look at how we generate
insights and patient outcomes
same with the biotech an IP space
whatever biotech spending up what do
they care about what kind of cereal
partnerships are they making versus are
you making as Big Pharma I think there's
a lot of opportunities for us to gather
and use things that grow both evidence
and of course this is one of these if
you go down you know multiple slides
indeed to look at exactly where in
clinical phase blot exactly where in
preclinical etc but I think just
connected to the very first slide we
talk about which is this long beam
pharmaceutical on value chain
I think this overlays well with where
real-world evidence may be used or maybe
generate it I think and finally as we
wrap up today a lot of people come to us
and we know we have conversations with
what is this process that we I mean
you've heard a lot about data to uses
the data how it's about prints verticals
within the value chain on how a
company's making partnerships type of
partnerships what kind of data is
collected or all the topics that we
talked about today really to understand
um what are the common challenges if
you're like yes like that's something I
want but where do I go from here to
where I am today I think common
challenges that we support we've you
know seen with a lot of our clients is
discipline structure but data which
makes it impossible to really aggregate
efficiently or effectively
there's too many input sources right now
it's a hundred percent manual the
location of these items this idea in
this position of a single source or even
a single platform is something that is
not not consistent or I guess it's a
it's a big daunting task to think about
where does all this data live and then
of course in pharma we look at what
systems are on GXP bound what our custom
ly made just for us so not a straight
out-of-the-box solution also um what are
some personal platforms like SharePoint
personal drive g5z drives what that
we're saving storing it
collaborating with this data I think
makes it difficult and I see that all
the whole landscape in one and a
full-blown suit at a time point and of
course because of that data is often
siloed and not correctly naming become a
problem even the same data to be called
six hundred different ways in different
systems let be manual or automated so
unless you are indeed data wizard you
may be looking at two columns of data
which is trying to same type of data but
you may not even know that each of the
way that in a siloed and then after the
app and then lastly although we may use
data innovation but really it's a
non-sustainable point solution so there
is a target in mind we bring in this
partnership we collect this data it
gives us this outcome but it's not a
sustained across all disease area it's
something that's not across all brands
done kind of I would say in silo but at
the point of need and kind of completed
more as a task than something as a
sustainability platform that we look
across all areas and we do across
multiple lines at the same time I think
what we look at when it comes to next
steps if you are suffering from some of
those items is of course I think you get
to that point where your data is
connected as best as possible to inform
in sites throughout the verticals within
a value chain is obviously not the
current existing data processes data
landscapes you create something
streamlined that you know where the
inputs experts are inputs outputs on and
to look at where can you aggregate where
can you streamline and where can you the
doors reduce maybe 50 60 sources and to
I would say you know 2 or 8 right but
really create opportunities to leverage
feedback data so we're in your process
today would you want and where what type
of data would you want in order for you
Jennifer I'm sure you've gone through
areas where you've thought wow if I've
had this type of data or if this type of
data was available for me at this point
I would be if we make of more decision
on going with X or Y due to X Y Z that
right but I think the approach 20 years
ago and how we do on business with data
and understanding and the connectivity
of data is very different so doing our
what we've done 20 years ago that's what
may not be working today and then of
course lastly to build automation to
enable data sharing so this is an annual
task as really the manual test that we
should be focusing on would be the
science and prying safety Africa
the data regulatory data rule the
evidence collection patient outcome
that's right me and only Pony
spreadsheets or sending an email what
not how do we build automation in AI to
create business question api's and
answers for us or to shares data stream
in a streamlined and efficient manner
between different disease areas between
their different clinical studies brands
etc so thank you so much for embarking
on this journey to talk a little bit a
very high level of course on the
different ways that data is more
connected than ever today through the
different value chains between clinical
phase one a preclinical clinical phase
one all the way to clinical phase four
after launch and real-world insights if
you have any questions but my bio page
is also in this deck that you can
download in addition feel free to
comment and any questions you have thank
you thank you for that informative
presentation would also like to thank
lab roots for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that this webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through May 14 2019 and as a final
reminder our speaker will follow up with
any questions you've submitted the email
that's all for now thank you for joining
us we will see you next time goodbye